I'm very happy for you I'm so happy and
your children I mean I I don't know I
just it's funny I think I have almost
like the the grandpa syndrome because
I'm so hungry for videos of children I'm
constantly pestering I pester Sona all
the time and she'll send me some that
are really funny of her kids basically
with hammers smashing their house and
just going crazy the funniest thing is
Sona is shooting it and laughing she's
always like uh oh oh gonna smash that
huh gonna smash that thing that great
grandpa left for us in his will oh there
it goes just you're just laughing funny
I beg her for these things and then I'm
like more more more I know and uh
suddenly I'm realizing that oh I'm just
in that phase where I can't I I love it
that kid thing is so fun I'm sure you
guys like we I'll we'll have her all day
and then I'm like oh finally and we put
her to bed I'm like oh and then if I'm
sitting there watching videos that I
took of her like I'm like I what are you
doing go live lady I do that about my
shows from the late
90s I that up for you yeah no no I I
watch them and I'm like Oh my God look
at him oh look at him he's he's still in
his
40s look how he eats with his hand yeah
look how cute you can tell he's
himself a and then I send them to people
you got to check this out yes this is me
with Christine baransky yes check it out
2002 wait why am I looking at this oh my
God aren't I adorable no oh my God you
seem weird face hurts but I would uh you
can't take that's the only thing I tell
parents is you cannot take enough video
like you just have to have cameras
rolling all the time because Conant it
doesn't yeah just constant funny stuff
it's ridiculous she's going pointing
right now and going uh oh everything's
uh oh which we but it's so funny like I
want to send videos to everyone I'm like
why why there no one's going to think
this is cute but me because I remember
when my friends would send me I'm like
oh great she's saying uh oh now I'm like
look our child saying uhoh like
everything's so exciting just means your
baby's neurotic yeah yeah yeah uhoh uhoh
uhoh uhoh you know later at 45 uh
oh well she would be if she got coming
out her face in her classes you oh my
God yes she is totally
immersed doing stunt work you know now
what are you gonna what's your feeling
going to be down the road because it's
so interesting it's like it's you got
started so young doing what you're doing
and then you think about your daughter
coming to you and saying I want to do
that and your attitude might be very
different like listen I survived that
but I don't want that for you I had such
a good experience growing up as an actor
I had like the best parents and I mean
Tom and I were actors I'm like she's
probably going to be something like that
or maybe the she's very you know she's
loves to show off and be on the video
loves to stare at herself I mean she's
she's our child for sure loves watching
her own videos loves to catches herself
in the mirror and like keeps looking
we're like yes we know um we get it you
know she's very entertained with the
things that she does um I think she
probably will do something like that but
my experience was so great you had a
good experience I really did and and I
started so young and if she wants to
what was your first gig your first pay
gig how old were you oh my gosh I did so
many Barbie commercials when I was I was
like the first Barbie girl yes like I
was probably between five and seven and
I did like 10 Barbie commercials I
actually yeah we I was talking about
this the other day I think we were
talking about it on Kimmel because they
wanted to see some of them and I
couldn't even F like they don't even
exist anymore like they're that long ago
um but those were my first couple things
and then the first I did a TV
miniseries where I played fisty Huffman
played my mom Donald southernland played
my grandpa and Tim mat played my dad and
I was five and I remember the exper the
weird part is I remember every moment of
it I remember my mom taking me there I
remember my little schooling I had to do
I remember going to set I remember
sitting on felicity's lap doing the
scene being told what to say and like
had like the best I mean it was just you
know I loved every second of it so my
experience was very good but my parents
were amazing and they did it right and I
did like a bunch of other things I
wasn't just acting I think we talked
about this last time I wasn't just
acting I was like okay now you have your
tennis lesson now you're going to go to
camp now you're going to do this so
there was never like I didn't get a job
it wasn't like that for me it wasn't
that effective for me it's so good
you're I mean it's it's fascinating like
the times I've spoken to Ron Howard and
uh he had such success throughout his
whole childhood but clearly his parents
were on the ball and same with Shirley
Temple you know just there's people that
whose parents are all over and then of
course there are parents that
unknowingly but they're not well they're
not well people and and we've talked to
some I mean we were talking to Natasha
Leon about it and she was saying her you
know she's being very honest she says
you know I I I she wasn't it's funny she
wasn't blaming her parents she was
saying they did the best they could but
they weren't well and she got tough deal
you know and you just think about all
these people whose parents are living
through their kids their own
disappointments yeah that's that's
really tough I just did not have that
experience I was very very lucky so you
know if that's what Matilda wants to do
I can't really tell her not to because I
loved my experience so much I can't be
like don't do that don't do that cuz I
you know I loved it eventually they have
to find their own way as long as you
control their finances right oh
yeah what yeah just isn't that the whole
point if your kids control their
finances it sounded very aggressive for
a it sounded devious actually did I
probably shouldn't have stroked my
non-existent goatee when I said it a
dollar sign above your head right now
what's going on you can see those I
didn't think any those when I drove in I
must control their
finances